we have accomplished magic literal Magic
from the perspective of most humans
who've ever lived we're capable of so
much more than hiding from the truth how
much progress are you actually ever
going to make
how much time we got bro
this episode is brought to you by
timeline nutrition which is this new
skin health line of products check it
out and get 10 off your first order
[Music]
you're here man in the house baritone
Day In the Flesh in the house is great
to be here thanks for the invitation
it's so hard to even get my hands around
tell me about it like how do we even
begin this conversation do you do so
many things you have so many interests
um you're curious about a lot of things
you're incredibly productive doing TV
shows and Puck and podcasts and all this
sort of stuff but why don't we start
with technology and the media landscape
this is your world it's a world that's
rapidly changing the tectonic plates
under our feet seem to be shifting all
the time so you know where are we in the
world of media right now how do you make
sense of it
um with great difficulty it's we're in a
a tectonic shift like like the tectonic
word and everything's changing really
really rapidly you know I I'm 45 years
old I was born in 77 Washington DC my
mom was a computer programmer for the
federal government and so I had a
computer in my household for longer than
most people my age regardless of the
economic and racial situation I came out
of which made it even more rare and so
it's always been an enabler it's been
fun uh and it's been this connective
tool and so we've got the internet cool
everybody gets a voice
and they're like oh we got the internet
man everybody gets a voice and things
that used to be hard for organizing and
amplifying are easy and that that can be
great for Trans kids
it's also great for like white
supremacist organizers too and there's
no like Morality In that
so with the speed of of like what I see
with media now is a bunch of stuff
I think of its role as to be in this
mirror that reflects us back to us and
helps tell us who we are and who we're
capable of and that's where my
frustration is greatest because I think
we're getting a very narrow
reflection of ourselves back to
ourselves and what these tools are
capable of is beautiful but what we're
actually using them for is a vast subset
of that beauty and so we get like ad
driven monetization of stuff we get uh
hyper focus on conflict and Discord
versus collaboration and creativity uh
we get subservience and following versus
kind of ownership and setting your own
course and we are what we eat and I
think we become what we see and we
become what people tell us we already
are so there's a lot of responsibility
in the media game and technology is
just adding fuel to an already raging
fire in terms of like possibility
confusion and sometimes uh chaos yeah
it's it's a very confusing mix this
weird Brew of optimism and Hope
um because it gives everybody a voice
and because those voices always have the
possibility of being heard being seen
to be leveraged to create Community yeah
the like but there's a competition in
which you know it's hard to identify the
signal from the noise and you know
there's a conversation around the the
Halcyon Days of the you know the old
media traditional media you know we grew
up with just a couple channels the
gatekeeper era a trusted you know voice
of Peter Jennings or or whoever it is
like how do you think about
um that romanticized version of of
Legacy Media from our childhood it is
seductive
to reflect fondly on like cultural norms
from the past
when things were literally simpler
not always better and and so I like
the the relative sanity or the pace of
that era versus now you know it was hard
enough to kind of keep up with
information when we had
dozens of channels and now we can't
measure the number of channels and we
don't really have an escape from media
you know you could turn off the
television
I don't know you it's hard to turn off
the Internet it's your phone it's your
alarm clock it's your mirror it's your
car it's your word processor talking
back to you like it's supposed to be
where I put my thoughts and now it's
giving me thoughts that's a very
different media relationship and it's
this always-on frenzy so in that sense
the past was more palatable and it moved
at a pace closer to our human evolution
the past also excluded so many
perspectives and voices that I cannot
simply say it was better
and I have to acknowledge that we know
about a lot of stuff and we know about
people doing great work in the world
because they can say it for themselves
and don't have to ask for permission or
get an A R rep to put their music up on
Soundcloud or or live stream their Rally
or their speech so I love that part of
the media Evolution and in terms of The
Trusted voices
there's
there's technological shifts there's
also Capital shifts and some of what's
happened in media isn't just like oh
technology speeding things up it's money
concentrating
the voices that we end up hearing
through a lot of these media channels
they make just a lot of money on the
conflict
and and going for the niche and trying
to make turn us against each other make
us feel that everything is this
existential threat
that's really good business I don't
think it's really good democracy and
that does feel like a significant shift
yeah from the media landscape yes sir
that we grew up in certainly with the
fairness Doctrine and some of these like
guard rails around what you could say
when right um and so now there's money
involved in defending insurrectionists
like it's profitable to pretend it
wasn't as bad as it was
and that's always been that there's
always been that strain in American
history it hasn't always had public
shareholders when reflecting on you know
that that era of media
um and that sense that perhaps it was
better because there was some level of
public trust in institutions that that
we lack now For Better or Worse
um obscures the fact that it was muting
out other voices and I think part of
that sentimentality comes from this
notion that it just made us feel safe
and secure and with the erosion of trust
in institutions across the board and the
proliferation of you know an infinite
number of media channels we have this
incentive system and you know you talk a
lot about systems and the systemic
nature such a nerd yeah of like how
things operate you know underneath our
media ecosystem are these powerful
incentives that do reward outrage and
and encourage conflict and the like and
you know we we've both seen
pundits and you know voices with large
platforms move in a particular and
somewhat predictable Direction because
of those incentives yeah which is
interesting in this era of lack of trust
because to me that feels more
untrustworthy what you are describing it
there there are so many angles into this
topic Trust
is that one of the biggest if not the
biggest headlines of our time
the collapse and Trust of every
institution that we have been raised
generally to trust
the church
ain't no trust there Catholic or
otherwise like attendance is down Faith
measured by certain measures is down
trust in government trust in business
trust in anything that we are supposed
to have some faith in to carry our
Collective will forward and in the
vacuum of that trust we've got a lot of
things that look trustworthy
because everybody can have production
values you know I worked for the onion
for five years right I know how to make
fake news look real right like that was
the heart of the onion which is like
satirizing the form of media it was a
great grad school education immediate
literacy to work there and like oh the
font Choice the layout the tone of voice
as we got into video the lighting so
that that looks legit what you're saying
is total nonsense but you look
trustworthy right now we can all choose
our own reality and we can feel
Justified and project confidence based
on so and so who looks kind of official
said it
and we can manufacture studies you know
with AI and stuff now like we can that's
a really you know that level of
fragmentation
filling the more cohesive trusted
universe and reality is is just a real
threat to social cohesion and to a sense
of collective belonging
that is a radical shift from the 1980s
yeah it doesn't bode well from my
perspective because when you layer on
top of that
um you know widening economic disparity
and this increase in in you know a giant
swath of our population that is that is
becoming more and more disenfranchised
and and marginalized and with that you
know resentful and and angry yeah you
know people are going to gravitate like
you know like iron fillings to a magnet
to the person who's tapping into that
that you know kind of base layer of
emotional
um disgruntlement and then in turn
monetize it
weaponize it uh and I think we're seeing
a lot of that right now and this is you
know I I don't know you know I don't
know if you have solution well you you
do have some solutions
you know I don't know how this plays out
and I think your point of the decline of
of
trust in institutions particularly
with faith-based organizations whether
it's a church or synagogue or you know a
mosque
um
those used to serve as kind of core
pillars in in everybody's respective
community and with that erosion we're
seeing it being supplanted with the rise
of you know these secular gurus that we
see online oh yeah the Instagram yeah
they're taking the place of the priest
and the rabbi and the you know the
whoever kale is the new communion wafer
man yeah well yeah exactly well that
that would be on the more benign you
know side of the spectrum there's some
more pernicious you know examples that
come to mind yeah
um but it it's meeting this deep need
that we have yeah that comes from a
place of of wanting to feel like they're
you're part of a community that you
belong and that there's somebody who's
like providing you with some guidance
counsel and and directives around how to
live your life yeah we need that yeah we
need that
everybody wants to and needs to belong
to something
and and the secondary question is
is the thing I belong to long-term
healthy for me
but the primary need is belonging and
that explains ganks that explains Terror
cells like the belonging is the thing
and there's a lot of people who studied
that way more deeply than me but I know
what it's like to feel alone and I know
that I have just out of a sense of peer
pressure as a kid and as an adult
you know to try to belong to something
you know subjugated my own sense of
right or wrong or appropriateness just
because I want to be in the group and so
you scale that up and you monetize that
and you incentivize that and you kind of
drown out or dry up options for healthy
belonging
that's all people people eat the food
that's in front of them if they're hung
it's that simple yeah
um
back to this idea of of incentives when
we look at you know media and technology
and this this sort of AD supported
um superstructure upon which the vast
majority of the internet is built right
that that not original sin we never
really signed up for that but that's the
way that it is we're Dragged In we were
opted into that yeah we were yeah
exactly
um and with and with the kind of
maturation of of New Media entities you
know like Puck that you're a co-founder
of and other sub stack Etc yeah there is
a different model which is this
subscription-based model which which I
like you know it's sort of making
significant inroads onto that that ad
model
um you know I love supporting people
that I think are good maybe not always
so great that stuff's behind a paywall
yeah you know it makes it harder for
people to access
um
but when I think of social media and you
know the kind of AD driven
um model upon which all of these
platforms live and breathe uh that
that's not great either right like I
would happily pay
uh to
be on Twitter if it was a healthier
ecosystem I'm not gonna you know like I
still have my blue check but like for
now I guess I guess that's going very
soon I don't know it's become like you
know how do you think about how social
media Works in that in that context and
and maybe even particularly I mean
you've been writing about what elon's
doing yeah it's hard to ignore the chief
twit I was on I've been on Twitter since
2007 very early very active recruited
thousands of people over the years you
know just dragged folks that you got to
be here it's cool and so I feel a sense
of responsibility to
what happens to the place more
importantly what happens to the people
not the employees just the people that
created the environment that Drew so
much of us to this exchange of ideas and
memes and fun silly things
what's going on with social media
like everything is complicated but I
think there's a couple of major pieces
of the puzzle you've pointed out ads
that's a major contributor to the
problem
also original funding The Venture
Capital model
requires companies to try to achieve
outsized returns
in areas that don't necessarily
need that in order to create a healthy
public discourse we don't you know we
had a guest on our how to Citizen
podcast Eli Pariser from new public
which is looking at digital spaces as
public spaces and how would we design
them the way we design a park or library
and we don't demand that our public
libraries return 10x uh you know Equity
value to their limited partners or 100x
we're not asking for the Brooklyn Public
Library System who's bored I said to
become a unicorn
but that library is a essential Public
Service a lot of great conversations
happen kids are safe there like and same
with the parks
we've shoved everything under this like
get rich people Mega Rich model and then
question why that's not serving our
larger Civic needs
Okay cool so we don't get married in we
don't have sex in we don't Worship in
the mall right generally speaking some
people do yeah that could be a fun meme
but generally speaking we have other
spaces to gather and so we put a lot of
pressure
on Outlets not designed to serve this
full need to fill in that Gap and some
of that's on us and then that lack of
imagination some of that's on the
capture of these tools and talent to
only serve that really high hockey stick
return thing that's a big part of the
shift that's required I'm not saying all
VCS or Venture fund Adventures are bad
I'm involved in some myself but I think
it's with something we ignore when we
talk about this a lot that the
contortion of the business model to make
very very wealthy people generally
speaking a bit wealthier
should not meet should not be the
driving directive for our public spaces
right but it's not even a contortion of
the business model it is the Paradigm
yeah right so these things operate
invisibly like you you know systems
economics all of these things you know
we're not we're not really looking at
the underlying nature of you know the
operating system to how our economy or
our democracy works because we've sort
of just assumed that's the way it has to
be right we're not asking the bigger
questions so when you talk about how do
you how do you instigate change
um maybe we should look at like do is
growth always good like like what's like
spoiler alert a minute you know like I
know that you you you had a whole thing
about like uh donut economics yeah which
is super interesting it's like does
every business need to be bigger every
year than it was before if it's a
healthy business like maybe it you know
it's just fine like let's say it just
produces a certain amount every single
year and the people that are employed by
it are are you know doing well and does
it need to be anything other than that
but we we have this judgment about that
that if you're not growing every year
you're failing or falling behind we are
so good at judging we we judge you if
you're poor
right if your poor it's your fault it's
because you didn't work hard enough you
didn't pull yourself up by your
bootstraps forget the fact you don't
have boots or straps it's your fault and
uh maybe you didn't pray hard enough
maybe you didn't go to the right schools
and that's your fault maybe it's your
parents fault but we kind of put a lot
of social outcomes on individual actions
and decisions and if you did really well
it's uniquely because you're very
talented you worked really hard you
studied and you was married and and that
is such a partial truth to be very
generous sure and it limits our ability
to create better outcomes for more of us
and I don't want to take things away
from people who've worked hard and done
well and I don't want to just give stuff
to people going to waste it it's not you
know there's no extreme is ever good but
we have overdone it on the
individualistic blame and credit game
and and that's a part of you know the
challenge we're living with in the
economic system right now and like
infinite growth I saw this speaker years
ago Al nor Lada
a-l-n-o-o-r never forget it because
that's a cool last name and I have a
cool name and he described infinite
growth
as cancer right is what it that's what
we call it in the human body when cells
just continue to replicate without
control and metastasize that's malignant
cancer and we do everything we can to
shut it down before it destroys the body
capitalism as we practice it on Earth
especially in the West
is predicated it's it's the Paradox it's
the Paradigm that is it's not the
contortion it's the mission
consume all resources to maximize
shareholder value everything's an
externality that doesn't show up on my
Excel spreadsheet and lo and behold the
host Earth is unable to bear that and so
it's really a bad business model to
destroy your addressable Market
but that's the logical conclusion of
this extremist interpretation of growth
sure yeah from a biological point of
view it's parasitic it's yeah yeah it's
malignant and terminal absolutely so
there has to be some I think if you take
it to that extreme the most
libertarian-minded person would still
have to acknowledge there is a limit
that limit of being unable to sustain
business life on Earth and then
hopefully something short of that
because that sounds pretty desperate and
desolate to live in a just barely
survivable environment Mars is way worse
so what is that limit in the donut
economics you put up Kate Ray worth she
takes that outer bound it's like this
ecological limit and then some floor
some inner limit of human dignity okay
what is everybody really need as a base
level we got all this inequality we got
massive houselessness and it's just
embarrassing and it's preventable and
it's sad and it's kind of stupid so how
could we raise the bar raise the floor
have a minimum so everybody's basically
taken care of have a maximum so we don't
commit mass suicide and then in between
we could Thrive there's so much money to
be made
so much money to be made so much joy to
be had so many products to be invented
and innovated around but Within These
guard rails and these bounds that sounds
like a useful provocation to me yeah in
a different way versus GDP which is also
a meaningless number like we literally
know from the mainstream economy it
doesn't capture the stuff yeah that we
should be measuring ourselves against
but that's what we Chase yeah so you
know you you do what you measure and
we're measuring the wrong thing and the
people who built the measurements
acknowledge it yet we still do it right
we're all you know interested in
creating us a sustainable environment
yeah like hopefully something we're
talking about right I don't know that
we're doing a very good job of it but
we're talking about it we're getting
better but getting better you know kind
of biological metaphor extension we
Thrive when we have sustainable
practices that support the biosphere
yeah from the cell all the way to Mother
Earth and those
ecosystems are most healthy and most
robust when they are diverse you want a
diversity of species this is you know
why we love the Amazon and you know
these are are really important and and
you know there's so much knowledge and
Truth in understanding that they could
be so easily applied to these other
systems that we're struggling with as
human beings from government to
economics to housing to you know social
media yeah
it's yeah the um
you know I I've been hired by a lot of
White Run companies and organizations to
talk to them about race stuff and and
during the summer of 2020 in particular
after it's like we need a black person
who can kind of come in and
Shake us up and shame us but with love
and some jokes I'm your dude for that
you know I'll keep it real yeah but I'll
keep your attention right not scare you
off too much you don't actually hear the
punch line and one of the things that I
I've been thinking about with this
diversity thing
so much of the way that conversation has
been set up is around
um
loss
giveaways
and charity right so I in my institution
of whatever am being asked to compromise
my quality
to give something to this undeserving
person from this special interest group
because the Brigade says so the liberal
Brigade The woke Brigade and I gotta
meet these new requirements and and get
off my core mission to help out some
scholarship kid some low-income person
some black person
and you know that that's a possible
interpretation right it's certainly like
there's some validity to that and if
that's the real truth like yeah you
should be upset about that
also
um diversity of perspective and mindset
and experience are just objectively
valuable
being able to have a window into a
different demographic for the
development of your products is going to
help you sell more stuff
and and recruit more talent and be more
sustained in your operations and that
person who you're kind of
condescendingly looking at because
they're different from you as less than
you
that difference could actually become
your strength if you saw it that way as
well and so
there is an opportunity there's like
literally more money to be made
by embracing that New Perspective rather
than by fearing it seeing it as threat
and only as losing what you're familiar
with losing familiar is a painful
process is not fun always to move homes
move towns move schools loss of familiar
triggers a whole bunch of psychological
stuff so that's not unique to white
people or men it's human
but we know that and we know that growth
and the diversity of experiences and
inputs can create a much more robust set
of outputs
economically and otherwise so how can we
shift the way we talk about this stuff
to focus on some of those gains like
Heather McGee is a great example of this
her book the sum of us and challenging
this premise of zero sumness in our kind
of racialized economy If I gain
something you must lose something for
example not the case we could actually
both gain more if we work together but
it's very easy to demonize and prey on
people's fears of loss and let the
conversation stop there right it is
presented as a binary yeah zero-sum
situation and when somebody is in pain
or anger or frustration because they are
in a situation in which they feel
they've been uh you know sort of not
given a proper chance or whatever
whether that's true or not
it it's it's baked in it goes all the
way back to you know the American dream
and rugged individualism and you're not
you know succeeding it is your fault
right and internalizing that guilt is
going to foment and turn into rage yeah
and that rage is going to look for an
outlet and it's going to look for a
victim yeah and yeah people out there
you know who are more than happy to
serve up you know the face of who that
person could be to then become the locus
of that anger and frustration and so to
un untie that knot unravel that and try
to tell a new story about possibility
you're confronted with having to you
know kind of work your way through
all of that to get to the core of that
person so they can actually hear you and
it's a layered
thing
um is really hard but it's really really
really really important
that you you know started this
conversation saying like I don't know
even where to kind of start in with what
I'm doing in the world it's a lot of
stuff
but if you strip away the outlets the
media formats uh the aspect ratios I am
trying to contribute to telling a new
story of us
that you know binds us together more
than it tears us apart and kind of gives
us something to build on together like
I'm not trying to take anything from
anybody I'm trying to create something
more with you that we couldn't do on our
own and that's the driving ethos of all
of these things we can't do that we
can't get past that fear and resentment
it goes from like I deserve this
ends in Rage but in the middle is like
resentment you got this thing that I
deserve
I'm salty about that
who's to blame oh scapegoat over here
it's a Mexican Muslim immigrant from
over there okay cool got my scapegoat
part of the reason that's such an
attractive narrative
is the the at scale miseducation of a
whole society for Generations about how
we got here and and we have we're now in
this era where telling the truth
just being real about American history
is partisan is uh described as hate
speech you know you're trying to turn
white kids against their parents
I
can I tell you a short story sure all
right
so my mother was the best mother in the
world
she got me through the crack Wars of
Washington DC she raised me and my
sister with no college degree she put a
computer in my life which has unlocked
every Economic Opportunity and the
reason I'm sitting here now is because
of her and I give her credit I put it in
my book how to be black greatest Mom
ever my mom versus your mom my mom wins
every single time no offense
also my mom wasn't perfect
you know and I realized some things
about her
um and her impact on how I developed
that are not great and it was a really
difficult reconciling moment to be like
oh this stuff goes back to that same
Saint arnida who I had created in my
mind
and I was really angry with her and I
couldn't talk to her because she's dead
she died in 2005 from colon cancer so
I'm sitting I'm resentful
with this perfect mom who I have been so
publicly grateful toward and told
everybody she's the best and she is also
she messed up and a couple of very
significant important ways that I've had
to wrestle with
and I had to break out of that rage
cycle and it was a simple realization
that she's a human being and of course
she's not perfect and that allowed me to
be less perfect and opened up a
relationship with my dead mother
that wasn't possible when she was here
I'm still getting to know this person
and now that I know her more Ah that's
love
when you know someone you love them
you know you can appreciate someone you
can celebrate them
loving is knowing and if you don't know
the dark stuff
you can't love the whole person and if
you only love them because they make you
feel good about you you're just using
them
so we scale that relationship concept
out to a country
we gotta love our country the way we
love our moms the way we love our kids
the way we really love the people we
know and we cannot love a nation while
simultaneously refusing to fully know it
that is false patriotism that is
exploitation
and so you
it's hard like I want to rant and Rave
against the people who are afraid of
critical race Theory and you know CRT
d-e-i-e-sg they're angry at letters they
hate Sesame Street I guess but
because of this one little nugget I've
had with my own experience of resentment
of a changing story
I get it
also we gotta get through it and we
cannot be cowards in that and there are
a lot of people promoting cowardice
restricting children's access to
knowledge
being afraid that your kid knows more
than you
is the opposite of good parenting
we all want our kids to be better than
us we should be excited when they bring
home some new knowledge and so to kind
of lock them into a restricted state of
knowing prevents them from loving fully
prevents them from being real Patriots
and that's the opposite of what we
should want so that's like a different
way to have this conversation I don't
want to get into like
this author that author do you have
faith in your children
right are you do you trust them enough
to know and really love America because
I can tell you with my mom I know her
better now
and I love her more now and I'm more
solid now because I've faced those parts
of her I was walking around with a
superficial false thing for a long time
and I think a lot of people wrap
themselves in the flag in that sense and
that's not good enough anymore
you had to come to that realization on
your own though right like you had to go
on a journey to you know wrestle with
your resentment and and finally get to a
place where you could kind of open your
aperture and accept her on different
terms
um but you I I suspect that you couldn't
have been told that when you weren't
ready like you need to get over you need
to understand this and get past it like
that was an internal you know kind of uh
Journey that you had to go on for
yourself right so when you think about
that idea you know how do you scale that
up yeah you can't foist it on America
they have to go on their own you know
everybody has to have their own kind of
Journey with this but we have to it is a
process of like
I think it begins with like not turning
a blind eye and kind of unraveling the
fear that
um is leading to these bad decisions
like you said that um I heard you say
that that you know America uses Amnesia
as a feature right like which is related
to what you're sharing right now because
we want to pretend certain things didn't
happen we want to think of think of it
in an idealized you know way when in
fact there's a lot of warts and healing
and health comes from
addressing diagnosing and and treating
that it does and it's
foisting is a great word
bad practice but I give you points for
using the word foist so foist and force
are not the right things they're not the
right language
model and invite are
and and that takes leadership
no we are what we eat we practice what
we see and so if we only see people
practicing Amnesia I'm like oh I guess
Amnesia is the way to be patriotic I
guess the way to love your country is
just to wave the flag and ignore all the
warts
it's not the only way and
enough modeling and enough leadership
and enough stories that demonstrate the
power
of embracing the full story can unlock a
a deep well of patriotism that we've
occasionally experienced you know that
it's asking people to do something more
than shop and vote
we don't ask very much of the citizenry
give me money
give this company money consume consume
that is like a low bar man and then
we're capable of a lot more and I think
there's a lot of folks in leadership who
in in of every industry you see it in
Hollywood and the way they talk about
the audience is there's a lot of
condescension they're not smart enough
they wouldn't get the Nuance they can't
handle the truth
it's patronizing and so I think we could
use and and I found through this how the
citizen work and just my life examples
of people who have more faith that's the
kind of faith we need that's the face
it's faith in each other to be able to
handle it
we've been through a lot in this country
we have accomplished magic literal Magic
from the perspective of most humans
who've ever lived rockets and all the
technological advances and the wealth
creation so we're capable of so much
more
and hiding from the truth and I just
think we need to hear that more we need
someone to believe in us and not just
demand that we accede to them yeah it's
a very interesting kind of Razor's Edge
to walk that you walk very elegantly
because you do lead with with empathy
and there's compassion about you and an
openness and an inclusiveness while also
being very clear about the truth and
where you stand on these issues right
which is very difficult to do
without it coming off uh in a way that
is you know off-putting in certain
circumstances right like like that's a
that's a really skillful Artful
dance that that that has to be performed
is that a fair
is fair I'm a good dancer yeah uh I mean
you see me on a dance floor man I cut it
up you know I got some training DC Go Go
music let's go but um
yeah it's um it's delicate there's a
there's a there's a risk and so in every
approach right to go so far as to just
keep people feeling good
not push into any discomfort
is not serving the truth
and we can't be free if we're not honest
if we live in a lie we're held captive
and we're enslaved to dishonesty and
that's not that's not Liberation so we
gotta keep it real we gotta be honest we
also have to be effective and not just
right
and it's like do you want to be right do
you want to be effective this is the
dance this is The Artful Dodge sometimes
and
it requires a calibration
to keep people engaged enough to hear
the truth
otherwise you're yelling into the wind
being right as you can all by your damn
self right and bringing nobody yeah so
you Pander to the ego into the sense of
comfort and fragility on the one hand or
you embrace the righteousness you know
on the other and got nobody with you
that's that's like a classic challenge I
don't think that's anything new to our
time if you're a Gen X dude like me then
skin care can feel a little indulgent
but I actually wish that I didn't wait
until my 50s to take care of my skin a
little bit better because hey it's our
largest organ it's essential to health
and it's our first line of defense
against environmental aggressors the
fact is as we age our mitochondria
generate less energy so anything that
you can do to boost these little power
plants is absolutely huge timelines
worked it out in their nutrition
products and now they figured it out
with skin care cracking the code with
this new product called mitopure which
is a patented version of a postbiotic
that they've discovered helps rejuvenate
mitochondria and promotes healthy skin
it's backed by 15 years of clinical
research they've got three products the
day cream the night cream and the serum
I've been testing them and using them
I'm really enjoying and I do think my
skin looks better and it looks more
refreshed it feels more refreshed and
you should check it out so to get you
started timeline is offering 10 off your
first order click the link in the
description below and use the code Rich
Roll to
all right back to the show
in in thinking about change producing
change creating Community around change
you know on the two po sort of ends of
the spectrum we have Grassroots
organizing ground up and then there's
top you know top down so take government
like what are we doing about citizens
united or you know lobbying and you know
you name it yeah gerrymandering and you
know all of these you know systemic
issues that drive us in a certain
direction right like how do we untangle
those knots and it's hard because
they're invisible and it's challenging
because you can't there's not one person
that you can go to you know it's like
it's diffused it's a lattice work right
um and it operates again kind of
invisibly to those who benefit from it
who are participating in it almost
unconsciously so that makes it
challenging yeah um and yet the sort of
Grassroots lobbying isn't quite enough
either and what's interesting about how
to Citizen and the episodes that you're
doing and the conversations that you're
having is like these are really creative
this is outside of the like the norm of
the three things that we typically think
of you know as you mentioned like you
know beyond voting to like well let's do
a March or let's do it's like no there's
a lot more here there's all these other
interesting creative things yeah
um but I guess the bigger question is
is
is addressing the binary of like do you
you know live to create these little
incremental changes within the system or
are we going to have to blow up the
system and create a new system right is
that a false binary yeah
all this little you know Grassroots
stuff over here but as long as Citizens
United in general all these other things
exist
how much progress are you actually ever
going to make how much time we got bro I
got I'm here
it's such a it's a beautiful conundrum
I'm starting to think of paradoxes and
conundras like these beautiful things
because you we cannot be baited into
uh the falseness of that dichotomy the
either or the binary it's a spectrum
like gender and light and everything
else and I think we exist along that
wavelength and then we gotta tap into
the wave at different frequencies that's
not really a cop out I think there's
there's value I hope it doesn't come
across as a cop-out so
we have been in this current season of
how the citizen focus on creating
culture how do you create a culture of
democracy so that the things that emerge
from that culture are more reflective of
small D democracy
and we don't just get hung up on the
citizens united and like the high-level
Supreme Court type fights
but that there is a way to connect the
local and the Grassroots to that larger
effort and and there's a lot of physics
theories and their fractals with Adrian
Marie Brown which is so much fun this
idea that small patterns replicated
every scale and so if we shift
internally we can actually shift
externally
I think that is a key to unlocking the
connection between Grassroots and
systemic and and that Grassroots has to
be expanded in terms of our
understanding of practicing democracy it
doesn't just mean a Grassroots petition
in your local school district
it means you know the way we kind of
articulate citizen as a verb in this
sense it means showing up and
participating it means investing in
relationships means understanding power
item is valuing the collective and we
can do that in our households
are we practicing democracy in our own
households and our own relationships do
we understand the power going on at home
do you understand the power going on in
this studio with our colleagues and
co-workers and funders and all like that
and are we cognizant of and are we
operating within that and how are we
using that power and so making people
aware and giving us literacy in this
gives us tools at the Grassroots to
start realizing the world the way we
want to experience the world and so we
may not have to blow up the system I'm
still open to the possibility but we
might seed a system
in the smaller space that produces more
people
who are coherent within this system who
go on into this system and say but I
really preferred the way we operate here
let's bring it in and so you're growing
a new culture and nothing has to be
blown up violently or metaphorically it
just fades it becomes less relevant
right because you've got a better the
better system in the petri dish yeah
begins to replicate because I mean just
Evolution
revolutionarily it will crowd out and
ultimately render uh you know
um mute the the old system yeah broken
and not replicated and here's a feature
here's a beautiful feature of the United
States and probably humans in general
but the way we codified our institutions
here with the constitution in particular
and the Federalist system we gave
ourselves a ton of Petri dishes States
federalism we gave ourselves amendable
source code Constitution we can append
it we can amend it that's commendable so
we have intrinsic tools
that are pro modification and
pro-experimentation so then we can take
an idea like citizens assemblies which
are these deliberative Democratic bodies
where basically you can script people
into government function and and group
argument debate deliberation around a
policy proposal that's widely
representative of the region not people
who could get elected because the
charismatic and pretty people who are
geographically economically and
otherwise distributed compensated for
their time kind of like jury duty turned
up to 11 and they wrestle with an issue
in Paris it's climate policy in Belgium
it's something else we have experiments
going on here in the United States as
well and folks are able to practice
self-government
with each other
listening to experts having eye contact
in these small groups and coming up with
much broader base support for a policy
because it didn't go through the filter
of campaign Finance right and Charisma
and extroverts only you know the price
of entry into our political system I
mean just the extrovert the the oh the
overt exclusion of introverts in our
system already leaves a lot of ideas off
the table yeah and I'm very extroverted
so that's going to dilute my good for
you but uh yeah many of us are not and
so you take that and then you can
imagine it okay that can work in like a
school that could work in a school
district that can work in a county
community level that could work in a
watershed area like we're going to state
and that can roll up into a national
government practice the way Ireland has
done where they did a national kind of
uh Civic assembly around their abortion
rules and how they went about legalizing
abortion and there was so much more
Nuance in that proposal because people
felt heard and part of what this
fragmented media landscape and this
competition with the cheap drug of fear
gets us is we want to feel heard and we
don't and the way the vast majority of
us feel about something there's no place
for us
we get pushed to the edges and the
extremes because it's life or death for
everybody and there's so much common
ground in the middle we have no process
to discover that because we're all alien
to each other because our process
doesn't let us see us as humans and I
and I think that that gives us a
distorted view of what of where most
people are absolutely we always see are
the extremes and we assume that like
everything is just like you know Up in
Flames but but we have you know the way
Congress works now
they are running on a social media
algorithmic like influencer model yeah
truly like you can better explain the
behavior of members of Congress based on
influence or economics than you can
based on representative democracy
they've been captured by a different
business model by a different operating
model and so we need a different model
to grow and replace that system there's
a group of veterans that come together
after floods and hurricanes Etc
because they have a sense of unit
cohesion because they have practice
at being on a team
and they use that practice at playing
well with others to be effective in a
totally non-combat arena in something
peace time and governed by different
rules rules of engagement totally but
structurally the same I the the public
at Large
we need practice playing well together
and if we can do that
in our Grassroots local areas we can
then use that to take on Supreme Court
policies and the lack of Ethics or
adherence to them in the Supreme Court
because we will have some Squad practice
in the minor leagues down here too and
so I think all of that kind of rolls up
you know in the same way that some of
that culture has felt like it's rolled
down and the the success of that type of
of model yeah
goes back to this idea of trust right
like it's it's you know it's the analog
experience of groupings of people
spending time together getting to know
each other that that you know breeds
that level of trust yeah and we throw
the word Community around like it
doesn't mean anything you know like the
word friend thank you sure yeah you were
talking about the mall versus like a
real community and how social media
operates like we have these Facebook
groups or other online communities but
they're not we we think of them as
communities and and perhaps for a lot of
people they're creating you know kind of
identity yeah out of their affiliation
to whatever group it is but because of
the ungated nature of them
um there isn't that kind of
process by by which you know the trust
is earned
um through experiences in the real world
yeah uh so talk a little bit about like
how you think about Community because
it's so yeah core to like how to Citizen
and and to the solution to all these
problems like real Community versus like
how we're sort of we've cheapened that
notion let me let me tell you how uh
Barack Obama taught me
work Community could be especially with
respect to the internet wasn't a private
one-on-one lesson
in my mind I'm like okay Barry he's
you're in the Oval Office he pulls me
aside he gets you on the phone you gotta
come down right now I gotta talk to you
and then a couple years I want you to
tell the people
so I was really excited about this
candidate
and especially his internet Embrace and
I remember the evolution of excitement
around his use of Technology
and first it was like okay he is a
single point in a node and he's using
the internet to better address
multiple publics and communities and
groups of people that's a little
Innovative he was the first to do it I
think it's we can't underestimate like
what a watershed thing that was at the
time so so that's level one
kind of digital community
upgraded broadcast capacity right and
and being able to micro broadcast
broadly to different communities
then the next thing I noticed was
listening right it's kind of the inverse
flow
tapping into all these communities
sourcing ideas perspectives Talent he's
still at the center of the diagram but
he's informed by all this social
listening and the agencies figured it
out and they call it social listening
posts in terms of the digital marketing
and advertising agencies that was
another evolution of the innovation of
kind of community and Communications
online
the third and final step I experienced
as a volunteer on the campaign offline
and online
he was at the center but the arrows
weren't flowing from him in terms of
broadcast they weren't flowing toward
him in terms of ideas or money which was
the real Evolution that the media
celebrated look at his fundraising
capacity sucking all these dollars from
small donors revolutionary the real
Revolution was connecting the endpoints
in the network peer-to-peer and I found
community and fellow volunteers
when I was on those streets in Dallas
and Pennsylvania and Northern Virginia
and online
in reddits and Facebook groups and Wiki
communities and so many different places
and we started making our own
policy sheets for the neighborhoods that
we were walking we made our own
playlists and our own posters and we
gathered and we self-organized and he
was the excuse
but he was a facilitator of that and
passively so he created some kind of
permission and enough inspiration for us
to run with the ball
Community has got to be about
its members seeing each other
not just seeing a principal not just
serving a principal there's got to be a
sense of peer-to-peer awareness and
acknowledgment that is enabled
perhaps by a central note of attention
but not only in deferential service to
it you know for outbound or inbound
attention or dollars and so it's used a
lot flippantly in Internet language
especially oh my community my community
my it's your audience
it's your customer a customer base is
not a community
an audience is not a community an
audience online
is not a community until the people
can really see each other I don't think
it's the most robust form of community
and so we can get into shades of grading
around like how intense is your
community how well thought out or how
deep is it but I think the high water
mark for all of us using that word is
can people connect to each other is
there a level of self-organization
self-actualization possible through the
members of that community
having agency of their own yeah that's
very well put I mean I think of it uh in
terms of oh I sort of think of it like
everybody wants to be part of a
community but
we already feel like we're part of these
fractured communities because they're
called communities they're like it's
like greenwashing it's like I feel
really good about buying this product
because it has the right label and
whatever it doesn't matter it it ends up
neutering like the real action by making
you feel better about something that
actually isn't real I guess to the point
that I'm trying to make here's another
you know
I want to try to bridge like some of the
things we've been talking about
in terms of how we might take
some of the ideas I'm online community
attention fragmentation and structural
challenges or impediments to progress
let me try it
your boy went to Paris life is good
sometimes and while in Paris with my
wife we met up with this activist who
helped create an organization called
make sense it's a volunteer group they
operate across the world largely outside
of the US but it turns out most of the
world is so they are globally
significant and they've evolved to a
form of climate activism that is the
most sophisticated model I've seen
they've got an app it's called regroup
r-e-g-r-o-o-p and they've taken hints of
be real in terms of a daily action and
like an alert it's now's your time and
it's coordinated climate action
informed by activists on the ground who
kind of know what the situation is and
analysts and researchers who studied the
levers and pinpoints of power in the
system so in this particular example
there's a oil pipeline in East Africa
that could do a ton of damage there's
decision makers in the European
Parliament in Paris and a French
government company and a Chinese
government company in American and
British insurers and Banks and each day
they give you something to do and you
see your progress you see how many other
people did it it's like oh 113 people
115 people 500 people 800 people and
they prepped something for you to do all
right we're going to send an email to
this group how do they know where to
send the email
well they haven't just started a
petition to protest the bank they've
gone to the bank
they've done a creative activation
outside the bank and they've had
conversations with bankers
and they said do you know that your bank
is financially supporting this project
here's what the activists in Uganda and
Tanzania in this case are saying about
no I had no idea let's go to the pub
let's talk about it they take them out
for a beer
and they get email addresses of other
people in the bank or they find out the
threshold inside that bank that creates
an internal alert for customers are
upset we might want to revisit this
policy and they do the same at the
insurance companies and the same with
the legislative bodies and so the
actions that we're being asked to do are
sophisticated
thoughtful and achievable
and they're prepped enough that it's
simple enough that it's also accessible
I'm like what is this and I can look
back I'm done 15 actions and it helps
with climate anxiety I'm doing something
and it's vetted and I can see how many
other people are involved so even the
way I describe Community I'm not in a
chat group with all these other people
but I have visibility into who else is
in this action with me I have trust
because it's people on the ground and
people from a researchy policy realm
kind of combining forces
to inform what they're asking me to do
and never had they asked me for money
not once whoa that's very cool and the
actions are all designed around
trying to achieve a result like they're
result oriented as opposed to and then
they make a bunch of noise and every
week they celebrate every week There's a
post internally and publicly we did 850
we did 1500 actions we had a meeting
with the CEO of the bank we got two
meetings scheduled this insurer just
dropped out they're not going to
underwrite the project increasing the
number to 25 globally or boxing them in
and here's the deadline we're working
toward this big un thing and here's the
deadline for
so there's a level of transparency too
so many groups that want us to do
something for a good cause save the plan
to save the Earth stop poverty stop
hunger Aid in this abusive situation
they don't let you in on the game
you have no idea what your ten dollars
is going to yeah and giving ten dollars
for me easy for a lot of people easy for
some people impossible
but a really low grade ask versus share
this message invite a friend to do this
send this email I was sending emails to
Japanese Bankers like yo konichiwa baby
I love Japan I've Got Friends there and
I would love to tell them that your bank
is on the right side of history and have
them move their company's business to
you versus your competition don't you
want that versus me having to tell them
you know carrot and stick I just think
that is an evolution
of how we citizen it's an evolution how
we think about how we use these digital
tools to mend democracy rather than
fragment it and it's fun you know it's
just literally like a way to engage yeah
in this heavy word activism which comes
with so much baggage I don't I'm not
educated enough I like money you know
like there's all kinds of other labels
that we carry that prevent us from
wanting to carry that one I'm nuanced I
don't want to pick fights this is just a
way to do something man and then you
having a platform to be able to talk
about that and like I'd never heard of
that yeah now I do yeah now other people
do
um which is a really cool privilege
right and I know that like how to
Citizen kind of comes out of this sense
that you know the news is all bad and
you know it's just it's disaster porn
and all it is is like all the terrible
things happening all over the world and
in truth like humanity is [__]
awesome and people are doing really cool
stuff yes those stories don't travel
quite as well
um but to elevate them and to find those
people who are you know coming up with
those kind of creative
innovative solutions to you know problem
small to existential is like really
important you know I'm glad you think
allow the visibility you know to rise up
there's um we're entering a phase an era
of like our human existence
where things are going to get harder
they just are they're gonna get more
magical right we're gonna have all kind
of technological Wizardry I'm basically
a spellcaster with these AI tools now
like and just the the power of my
creation is like How Could You cast that
spell did you turn someone into a
butterfly or a frog depends on your
prompt
at the same time the temperature is
literally Rising
weather is getting more volatile income
inequality is worse trust is down and in
that kind of environment of increased
seeming scarcity we're going to have a
choice of who and what we listen to
and and what we consume informationally
and the quick hit the dirty drug is
going to be blame somebody
the reason the weather's bad uh
homosexuals
trans kids in their bathrooms they've
smited Jesus or they've offended the
Lords and I know I just ruined you know
I really really misstated the religious
case against homosexuality but it's a
terrible case so I don't mind that
there's going to be scapegoating of all
kinds of people that have nothing to do
with our current situation
the immigrants coming across our
Southern border are long-term truth like
fleeing a problem we created in the West
in America in particular we so cranked
up the temperature on the planet that
their droughts at the equatorial region
are driving a bunch of displacement and
they're naturally migrating North people
have always fled to others turns out
we're the cause
so we're mad at them for stuff we did
okay so you can listen to the people
telling you that it's their fault that
we have to draw up borders and that the
little scraps we have left we gotta
fight to the death for them or
you can listen to the people said isn't
it you can plug into something like
regroup you can listen to new public
about how we create a different kind of
discourse in space Adrian Marie Brown
and how we can practice
belonging
practice democracy practice problem
solving with a whole different Spirit of
celebration of what we're capable of you
said it like we're awesome humanity is
awesome
you've had a bunch of awesome people on
this show remind I was just listening to
Rick Rubin yo yeah we're amazing
and and wouldn't it be so great
to to feed ourselves and to heal
ourselves and to nourish ourselves with
that kind of quality diet
going into these very extraordinary
times then the diet we know is poison
that's like a no-brainer to me man I
know what I'd rather listen to yeah I
think the other
thing that that speaks to is is a path
to to meaning and and purpose and
fulfillment which I feel like a lot of
people are are desperately in search of
or are lacking in their own lives
um and and to kind of invest yourself in
in something important that's bigger
than you where there is real community
and innovative solutions and a real need
for people to you know step up and and
show up this is affording you know you
that possibility for yourself because
it's in that act of service yeah
um that you find that right and that's
that unlocks happiness it's like again
almost like you know like a biological
system like you know hey go do this
thing that we need you to do and
actually you're gonna all the stuff that
you're upset about like suddenly life
gets better and that's the good drug
right that's the good hit that's the
healthy adrenaline you don't but this is
the broccoli to the to the you know to
the cheeseburger but it's not even even
calling it broccoli I think it's like
freaking like locally sourced fair trade
deep dark chocolate you know versus the
commercial diluted high fructose corn
syrup [__] I'm very close from very
early proud of it I went to Great school
but I'm just saying like you know
when you've had like a piece of fruit
that's just real right a fresh
strawberry right out the dirt that ain't
Coastal I mean in some cases California
we feed the world so it is but that's
not like Los Angeles Twee Elite stuff
that is like people working with their
hands they already know this you'd eat
that fresh strawberry any day from the
plastic wrapped globally shipped you
know genetically preserved
facsimile this cosplay strawberry that
we're served up to be shelf stable and
beautiful but it's empty calories right
so even with the same fruit there's a
difference and we know
we know the difference it's just that
the the shrink wrapped one is a lot more
air time and a lot more investment
but the the one that was grown in the
dirt
that's got the nutrients we need that's
that's the real thing and and we deserve
the real thing we just don't have time
you know I think there's also this other
kind of
headwinds Crossroads we're coming to
were like distinguishing real
it's getting harder sure right like the
the the the facsimiles and the cosplay
and the stimulated realities
are really seductive in themselves and
harder to distinguish so there will be
this parallel movement for real
for tangible not virtual you know
tactile not haptic and and 3D real
immersion like in a physical sense
rather than in a virtual sense and just
getting out in nature you know and being
with other people and what you described
about you know the the purpose
reminded me of Jose Andres World Central
Kitchen
and the you know this guy's infectious
in the best way and what he helps unlock
through that type of leadership giving
people a way to channel that sense of
loss isolation morning
at the darkest moment creating some
light feeding people using the local
people on the ground to do it
now we all got something to do and we
feel better even if we got no
electricity
we feel better and so the material thing
ain't the thing right it's the it's the
emotional thing it always is with us
yeah another example that that came to
me you probably know Scott Harrison
charity water yeah yeah it's a very
similar yeah kind of Arc that he went on
to that to that kind of a place yeah
right yep so so when when reality itself
is for sale
and we can have a superficial experience
of it
where are we going to fulfill the Deep
need you know for for that real
connection and that real sense of
purpose and real sense of belonging I'm
not saying it's impossible through the
virtual world I just gave you a case
with regroup where it's all powered by
technology but I think it's important to
keep our eyes out as new waves of tech
you know hit the shore
what parts of us are they drawing out
what are they asking of us and is it the
part of us that we want to amplify
and those new technologies are going to
hit the shore I think sooner rather than
later I mean we're on a curve already
it's going to get so much more insane
and that breeds instability 100 you know
in your sense of purpose belonging and
meaning
for how you do everything I remember
maybe 15 20 years ago having this
realization not unique to me but it was
unique
you know at the time as in I hadn't read
it anywhere
the distance between us
is growing
within a generation you know for
thousands of years most humans live to I
don't know 40 years old lost their teeth
died young right we just didn't have uh
I mean I'm not talking about like the
biblical error when apparently they
lived for hundreds but generally
speaking life was you know brutish and
short and then we slowly expanded that
but a great great grandparent would have
a lot of practical advice and wisdom for
the great great grandchild
and now an older sibling is having a
hard time doing that with a younger
sibling five years apart
so that's a level of social
fragmentation familial fragmentation
what do you have how do you parent your
child
how do you Mentor your Nissan nephew
when you didn't go through anything like
this yourself and the thing they're
going through now is going to be
radically different six years from now
one year from now not to mention the
governing but even take the governing
just keep it in the family
it starts at home and so if we're not
able to pass on
values and wisdom and best practices
within a generation because the reality
in which we're operating is changing so
radically our frame of reference is
totally gone
then we're kind of we're untethered yeah
it makes it impossible to there's no
coherence exactly from one not even you
know and not even generation to
generation but you know within
generation it's just it's the
acceleration of change is so massive
yeah what we have to share then suddenly
becomes irrelevant almost overnight and
and so but truth is always truth there's
always wisdom that transcends whatever
is happening we may not be able to
relate to the specific experience of
what it's like to grow up with you know
technology X but there are still you
know some some there's there's an
architecture of of you know how to be in
the world there's a there's something
underneath that superficial reality
right whether it's virtual or physically
tangible
our Humanity
has some consistency right we have an
emotional experience
we have desires and needs we have fears
we have a sense of belonging or it's
opposite a sense of purpose or it's
absence and so we have to figure out a
way to to tap into that deeper frequency
if you're trying I mean I remember
telling businesses when I would advise
them on social media strategy you know
don't ask me what your Vine strategy
should be
Vine will one day not be here
what's your story right and then you
figure out how you're going to express
it in the medium of the moment
we all need to kind of get below the
surface it's increasingly important
because the surface is ever changing and
I don't have a simple answer for that
but I just acknowledge it as a major
contributing challenge to the sense of
rupture and disruption that we're all
facing yeah I mean that part is
unprecedented yeah the big thing here is
you know we already feel like we're in a
post-truth world but we ain't seen
nothing yet but the under current of
humanity is that true that you know this
this notion that truth is important
right like yeah we agree on that right I
mean what's true and not true like
understanding the difference between
that is important but I feel like we're
creeping towards a situation where
there's going to be a lot of people who
would rebut that yeah and say actually
truth is not important what's important
is is winning or or you know audience
capture or just making sure that your
narrative is the one that's on top and
when you have you know when the Deep
fake technology it's like the ability to
obscure truth or tell whatever story
that you want to tell uh in the most
convincing way yeah completely
untethered from anything real or true
you know it becomes it becomes you know
pretty
uh apocalyptic we don't just need a sort
of
a
competitive system we don't just need a
system in which truth competes with
untruth
we need a system in which the incentives
for truth compete with the incentives
for untruth and and where we're where we
are now that is not really the case you
know like
you can be outlandish and dishonest and
generate the markings of reward
through retention through likes through
money for being untruthful and the
punishments aren't quite aligned with
that either so so the downside could be
turned up and the upside could be turned
down meanwhile
for those of us who love and value truth
we've also got to build a system that
rewards it and and offers demerits for
undermining it we've got to be able to
to show
transparently
that truth has value
and and I don't want to just sit here
and say yeah the truth is always better
like clearly historically speaking it
doesn't always win because
untruths have been able to attach
themselves to things that people value
and ultimately we value belonging
perhaps as an example more than we value
truth we value self-preservation more
than we value truth
genocides are built on lies all of them
they somehow compelled millions of
people to participate actively or
passively in them because they saw
something in it for them
self-preservation belonging lack of
ostracization
to uphold a lie so so lies had a lot of
co-conspirators and we've got to make
sure we rally it when it's so much
easier to create and spread a lie we
need the truth to have some allies yeah
and some rewards built in I I haven't
thought about that at all this is a real
time like oh snap what does that even
mean for us but I think if we ignore or
try to pretend
that the truth is just obviously better
we are in for a while to hurt because it
isn't obvious a lot of times no and
there's debate about what is the truth
now who's truth my truth Your Truth yeah
and then that brings in you know a a
sort of freedom of speech argument I
mean this is you know the battleground
of this right now is you know happening
on social media trying to figure out
like how how to create healthier
incentives
um to do that and I don't think we're
doing doing it in a very elegant way I'm
confident there are solutions out there
to do that I mean if you if you were to
create a social media platform wouldn't
do it love myself too much but like just
imagine you know if you
if you had your druthers and you could
create something that would have the
proper incentives that would you know
Elevate like a core set of you know kind
of higher values around how humans could
organize communicate coordinate Etc I
mean if you do you have a sense of what
that would look like a couple of pieces
in mind here
um what I'll cite once more new public
it's a great organization
um that is trying to answer this
question about how as they phrase it how
we create healthy and thriving digital
public spaces of Which social media is a
part but the design of those they've
identified these core principles and
signals that are just a great
provocation to the communities building
spaces for themselves you should go
through this process and the process
doesn't in any case in any instance
involve just installing something that a
venture capitalist wants you to right
that's just they've asked none of these
questions that is not their business
literally it's not their business so
they don't need to I'm not trying to
change who they are I'm just trying to
let us be real in other words throwing
scale out the window throw scale out the
window at the beginning and throw that
Financial
um recovery at scale out the window so
look to new public for somebody's
principles I'm thinking of an old friend
who lives in France Felix Mark Hart and
he has created
this community called black elephant why
is everything happening in France this
is like the third I'm not that story I'm
not a paid influencer or a marketer for
the Republican who knew that like France
was way out ahead every issue there's a
lot of there's a lot of beautiful things
happening outside of the states
um and I think we should all you know
remember that the world is huge and and
old there are things we can learn from
from people who are no longer here or in
more diminished numbers like indigenous
people everywhere so Felix has created a
black elephant and it's kind of a social
network and that you meet a group of
strangers it's kind of curated but you
start with like this pod and you answer
three everyone answers one to three
questions
that are emotional
in in origin you know what was the first
time you remember feeling sad
right there's nothing about your job
there's nothing about what school you
went to it's not a professional Network
you're not showing off your Creations
you're answering some prompt about your
essence
in a place where you don't know most of
these other people and what happens I've
attended one of these
and I find myself being vulnerable and
connecting through vulnerability with
other folks I mean AA groups have
something like this all kinds of
counseling circles do this and once you
have that kind of emotional link
then there's a digital platform to plug
into and you can see how there's other
black elephants thing and there's an app
that they're building and you start to
have a network of people you deeply know
and then you realize oh you're a
creative director at such and such cool
but it's you you enter through the heart
is how I would describe it so I think if
if I'm designing a system I take some
cues from essentially like Urban Design
and participatory design of public
spaces that new public is leaning on I
take a page out of the black elephant
book to create an emotional connection I
take a page from uh Esra al-shafi and
Bahrain who built this lgbtq social
media Network where you don't just get
to do everything in the first instance
there's an onboarding process yeah I
heard you talk about that like you have
to you have to earn the trust over time
you don't just get the keys to the whole
thing like a video game yeah right and
so you don't get all the tools and all
the weapons and the access to all the
maps you have to go through submissions
sometimes with other people to
demonstrate 8 your understanding of the
Norms of this space and your
participation and belonging through your
actions not your terms of service
Declaration on day one show me don't
tell me and then I'll let you into the
next level so those are three tangible
groups the other thing dude like
I would build a network with some
scarcity
right you get
a limited number of posts maybe you get
coins or credits but I want to force a
pause
on the interactions I don't it'll be a
failure of my social network if if we're
telling you know our team leadership
people are spending four hours a day in
here that means we have taken you away
from your life
for at least three and a half hours that
we didn't need because I want you living
your life too and I don't want to Define
your life I'm not Mark Zuckerberg like I
don't want to capture you
and I want to colonize your calendar and
so much of what we have built in the
social space is this winner take all
attitude about our time which is all we
got like even people without money we
got time and if you're gonna take that
too what am I I just I work for you now
we're all like uncompensated laborers in
the algorithmic overlord system from a
handful of very wealthy people I don't
want to replicate that system so build
in a little scarcity there's a window of
time if you miss it it's cool
congratulations
you get a fomo award you know and so
shift the vibe on that yo you maybe I
should start like a thing or maybe I
should just play in the existing ponds
there are so many that people are
spinning up now
um that experiment with just these dials
yeah those are all really yeah those are
all really great ideas and that idea of
of only allowing you know access for a
certain amount of time and preventing
instantaneous replies and responses to
enforce sort of a pause when agitated
it's like that thing like don't send the
email you know like wait send it
tomorrow like absolutely you know
there's just a cooling off period you
know
right it's like the Brady Bill for
social media posts you know what I'm
saying you're just like you yeah you hit
send and then it sits for 24 hours right
and then you know 22 or 23 hours before
you get sent it back and it's like are
you still are you sure has anything
changed do you want to think about this
again
and if you still want to send it go for
it and people will also know you thought
about it here's a last element
polling you know I remember I get into
to interact with great people through
this podcast digital minister of Taiwan
Audrey Tang what they're doing with
digital democracy over there is
inspiring especially the stresses on
their democracy from China
um
how we ask questions in polls and how we
see each other
is really warped right now we get a ton
of yes no binary representations of
ourselves rather than a reflection of
the spectrum and so there's a different
way to ask questions
to ask
how do you feel about this thing and how
important is it to you
right just the secondary level of how
important is it to you create Shades of
Gray and so I can see that on the trash
pickup resolution
you are a hundred percent committed this
is do or die and you're going to spend
your polling points
you're going all in on that 10 chips on
the tissue voter right versus like for
me it's one chip but I'm gonna preserve
my nine for something to do with the
water policy you know there's five
things to vote on here and I'm gonna
allocate most of my resources so it's a
system is called quadratic voting that's
kind of a way to exercise it but there's
also a different way maybe it's called
quadratic polling
where you visualize a community and you
get to show them how they feel about
things there's such a challenge of us
being told here's how they think about
you
Republicans
yo these Libs
they want to destroy your way of life
black people these white people they
don't think you matter at all white
people these black people like
immigrants so we speak in such extremes
about each other we're really given an
opportunity to speak to each other and
we're certainly not shown
the the level of nuance in our opinions
about all these issues there's no one
there's very few people who just want
abortion all the time
that's extreme like that's just a lot of
abortion you know what I mean but
there's also very few people who are
just like under no circumstances ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever and
in America in polling from Pew has shown
this
a great swath like 60 70 percent are on
the same page about the window of time
and the kind of exceptions and the broad
availability of this particular service
that is not to be celebrated but also
not to be restricted
and that's a conversation we're not
allowed to have right same thing
exactly you know if the polling reveals
that you know the vast majority of
Americans are are in that middle Place
yeah nationality when it comes so we
need better mirrors and I think what
social media has given us so far is also
perverse warped fun house set of mirrors
creating the Marjorie Taylor greens you
know creating that hyper viral type
moment
that has nothing to do with governing
and very little to do with what most of
us want and very real in terms of of the
you know the impact that it has on on
Behavior outside the digital space like
these these are not benign no and then
they and then they create a situation
where I think you think
this is the most important thing in the
world to you
and you're willing to do anything to me
to get it done
and that just that ain't true that's a
misrepresentation
um and you know we had this guy Tim
Phillips from Beyond conflict talking
about that in a very recent episode
we don't hate each other as much as
we're told we do
but somebody wins when we think that
about each other
and so we all got to take a step back
and check ourselves like
who told me
that this neighbor of mine
hates me today
and what was in it for them to do that
have I actually interacted with that
neighbor with that person
and that that's a around a ton of things
and I could I could play it across a lot
of ideological divides from every
perspective we all have a heightened
sense of distance from each other
because somebody's blocking our view
well that seems to be a big
piece of the television show right
America Outdoors yeah America Outdoors
like getting you know let's let's let's
go travel across the United States and
let's talk to all different kinds of
people yeah it's it's sort of draped in
this idea of of being outdoors but it's
really about kind of where Americans are
at and and who they yeah
oh my God I'm so glad yes it's an
outdoor show I love nature of course
that's so smooth you're like a
professional I just maybe done this a
few times maybe I should host a podcast
I wish that for you so much
um this yeah America Outdoors is what
you said it is it's it's a way of
viewing America
from the outdoors and and what I just
described about the distance we perceive
between us
is narrowed greatly
when you're standing on shared ground
and so I have been a person who has gone
on cable news or gone to my blogging
corner or my tweeting corner and popped
off
about that other America those people
over there who want to do this to my
people over here and I've been uh
embellished often you know in my sense
of righteousness around that
it's very different to like be in a
shared vessel going down a river with
someone it's very different to be in a
natural and literally natural
environment versus a manufactured Studio
or social media environment sharing
space moving at the speed of a river or
a tree or a meadow
and then engage in a conversation and
that conversation is not starting with
what do you think about guns right what
do you think about abortion like whoa
whoa what kind of what kind of parties
do you throw where that's like the
opening question it's like hi my name is
what brought you here let's start with
where we are what does this place mean
to you how did you discover it why are
you fighting to preserve it what are the
threats and risks what do you get from
it all of these immigrant Refugee kids
in Idaho are feeling more American
because they're literally tapped into
the physicality of America and they're
enjoying the woods and the hiking and
they're getting to connect across their
various languages with each other
through the excuse of a hike
oh and they're really loving those
purple mountains Majesty that's so cool
going to a conservative community in the
Chesapeake Bay
and literally the trumpiest town in
America by some measures and being able
to see the real impact of rising sea
levels and climate change and feeling
the emotion of the mayor ooker who is
near tears telling the story of how he
had to exhume the graves of his
ancestors because the bay was taking him
back yeah and buried him in his own
backyard
that was the same sense of mourning that
I felt
from the indigenous community on the
South Fork of the Idaho river the salmon
people
who ever since a morning about the fish
that helped their people come into
existence and Thrive for so long who can
barely survive in their own home either
they're being they're both being
subsumed By changes in the water
one directly in their Human Experience
One and indirectly in the animal
experience which they don't see as any
different from their human relatives
and so
we're bridging this conversation between
trumpy crabbers
in the Chesapeake Bay and uh uh you know
indigenous folks in what we call Idaho
that's a that's a great excuse yeah yeah
it's beautiful it's beautiful and it
also loved the show and I get to do cool
stuff yeah you get to go to cool places
and it also allows you to tell a new
story or perhaps a more on a story about
our relationship as a country with the
outdoors because we have this kind of
calcified idea that when you when you
speak about you know exploring the
outdoors it's uh you know it's a it's a
white guy with a backpack
yeah uh and and in fact that's not
really the case like when you unpack
um
you know a more uh a more honest story
around you know the indigenous uh the
the various indigenous populations and
cultures and and how they relate to the
outdoors and what outdoor access means
and that of course comes into race and
and how
um marginalized populations uh you know
struggle with their relationship with
the outdoors in terms of safety it's
access things like that and then and
then it's you can't do a travel show
without it being kind of a climate
change show too right like when you yes
because wherever you go you're seeing
it's different we're seeing a disha of
kind of what's happening right that's
sort of like the low the under you know
kind of the the hum beneath everything
it's The Uninvited co-star of every
episode right oh here goes climate
change making an appearance look at the
smog smell the fires uh the thinness of
the ice the the sloshiness of the
snowfall or the excessiveness of the
rain or snowfall depending on where we
go it's real and it and so this is I
love working with PBS on it I think it's
nice to like do a project with public
media
I love the luxury of being able to visit
all these places just as the little kid
who went camping and still loves biking
and walking outside sometimes called
hiking
um that's that's a great privilege but
you know it also makes
real
like the the climate change story and
experience is we were in Maine recently
we're kicking off season two with uh a
week in Maine
and the week we were there was not as
cold as it was supposed to be it was
still pretty cool compared to California
but two weeks before frigid blast was an
unseasonably warm you know February week
in Maine and one of the things I was out
there to do was an ice Harvest
and uh there was just not a lot of ice
to harvest it was and you can see they
have the catalog each year of how thick
the ice is on this Pond and it was very
thin this year a lot of people fell in
it was a shallow Pond no one was injured
but that's just a no better illustration
it's not just the polar bears on Ice
it's like humans and this tradition that
they have and so another indicator as we
discuss with technology of our changing
reality
so even as the virtual environment we're
in is rapidly changing the physical one
that we could have counted on is going
to be very different it's going to mean
something different to be a Mainer than
it has
for many generations it's going to mean
something different to be a southern
Californian or an idahoan or an Arkansas
and so again that's that's an incoming
strike
on identity
and so if your granddaddy can't take you
out the way his granddaddy or your
grandmother can't take you out the way
her grandmother did
just another Link in the chain of of
human connection that is changed
not just the climate yes us yeah how
does all of this
weigh on you as somebody who's been an
activist for so long because you carry
yourself with such enthusiasm and
optimism
yeah but you are you you have this kind
of ebullient personality and you are
outgoing extroverted yeah and you're a
comedian um sometimes and you have you
have Charisma and so it feels like
you're able to to hold it but not let
not let it you know completely you know
erode your soul
um but I think there's another
kind of aspect to this because you wrote
about it this Paradox of of you know
what it means to shoulder that kind of
responsibility and with this call to
action
around how important it is to like take
care of yourself especially if you're in
this game and you want to be in it for
the long haul like you can't just martyr
yourself on the cross of your cause yeah
you know because I think a lot of you
know a lot of people they they feel like
taking care of themselves is indulgent
you know when there's so much harm that
needs to be addressed or or spoken about
yeah uh it's a
so I do feel the weight of what I have
chosen to carry or what history has
pre-packed in my rucksack
um increasingly as I age I think it's
becoming more apparent and my youthful
energy
I can't just like push through the way I
might have in my younger years my body
gives way my mind and sometimes my heart
and I'm just like oh this is
I'm I'm not new like there's been a lot
of people doing this and if I'm still
doing it is that an indicator that it
can't be done right there's there's a a
deartha hope at times and just the sense
of uh
impossibility around a lot of this and I
do experience that I don't just believe
we're gonna get through this and it's
gonna be better like I believe that's
possible
I don't always believe we're going to do
it and I sometimes question
how much of my energy I should be
devoting to this I can't make that my
whole identity
otherwise I ebb and flow with the
success or failure of each little thing
right and I gotta tether myself to
something more substantial and stable
and Lasting other relationships
other activities other things to Value
outside of that construct and that that
lens on reality and so seeing things as
a struggle
and seeing things as like some historic
ancestral baton passed from my enslaved
people to me to make cool cool but also
like I need a nap you know it's not easy
to watch something stupid right now I
need to sit and not listen to a podcast
to better myself right
and more importantly perhaps not to feel
guilty about it and it's like but that's
okay and so to actually celebrate it
there is um again a lot of these things
you know some of this stuff
is newish to me it's not new to the
world and so Audrey Lord a great you
know former living American who's
written about the beauty and power of
rest and rest as resistance and
um self-care as as a revolutionary act
especially for folks born with a sense
of Burden that you got to struggle and
that applies you know really obviously
to like a black body in America but
there's a lot of people born into that
depending on your family there's
immigrant stuff there's your parents who
did their own business now you gotta you
know take on the mantle now some of you
we all inherit some stuff we didn't
choose
and then at some point in our lives we
realize we have to decide for ourselves
is this me is this who and how I want to
be
and if I opt out of that
how do I live with in a positive sense
that choice and not shame myself or feel
bad or guilty about it despite what
others you know maybe in my own family
might say or my own group might say so
that's a part of how I move through all
of this and I'm getting more comfortable
at tapping out
and and not making it all be about some
epic journey to help America figure out
it's american-ness like you know at the
end of the day
America's gonna America
and whatever fruits there are of of the
the seeds that I'm helping plant or
maybe more accurately the watering that
I'm doing of seeds that I've found in
the ground
I won't see most of those fruits and so
I also have been trying to find ways to
be feel a sense of reward and
satisfaction from the act of watering
not from the Harvest yeah yeah I like
that uh America is gonna America I mean
we can citizen my friend right we can
and and I think there's something
there's so many parallel models of this
you know we did a project with the NCAA
a pilot program with a bunch of mostly
basketball coaches
who are trying to help their student
athletes feel more of a specific agency
especially coming out of the summer
2020. you got a lot of black athletes a
lot of not black coaches and these
athletes like we need to do more than
just play ball you know and we and they
felt their power yet the power of
attention presumed leadership literally
more visibility they're very tall people
and um
how you think about you know Sports is a
powerful metaphor for this physical
activity as well
we got to make the game itself
worthy not the outcome
right if it's only worth doing if you
win
I don't know if that's like worth all
this investment and so winning is great
playing is the thing and every coach of
every level of Athletics in any part of
the world and every player who's been
through it will probably tell you
yeah maybe they won a championship maybe
they remember winning game but they
remember the bonds they remember the
shared suffering the shared losses and
the shared wins maybe more so I remember
the rides in the team bus
I remember the trust that my coach
placed in me I remember learning from a
fellow team man I remember the console
and from men you know and boys emoting
in a way that generally wasn't promoted
and so I think you know with the citizen
work
yes outcomes yes we need goals and we
want to but the culture of it like the
game itself how we play it
is always more important in the
day-to-day than the scoreboard and if we
play well
then I think the odds are we'll be proud
of the results
even if an individual match we don't win
so part of that is is just honoring the
struggle and the journey yeah and and
not like doing it so that it's over but
just sort of you know kind of being
present with it
and understanding that there's
nourishment even in that struggle in the
relationships yeah on the path towards
take the victories before the game is
over also
um there's time in between games there's
timeouts there's half times like rest is
also built in to any labor
um and so we all have to
kind of moderate the intensity sometimes
and like breathe and and move at a pace
befitting our bodies
and as much as you know our minds are
being drawn to faster more parallel
we're still in these meat bodies and
we're just these like
thumb having simeons right who are
trying to make sense of all this stuff
and and it's hard I was talking with my
wife a lot about calibrating the time
skills she has this theory that we're
just not meant to exist
especially at these different Paces
simultaneously and that we're being
asked to shift times constantly and some
of that is really disruptive as well so
like
finding a pace and easing into things
you know wrap up slowly ramp down from
something
don't just hard cut yeah you know from a
peaceful activity to an intense you know
analytical thing to some physical stuff
and back that also like wears out our
internal Transmissions I think in the in
the podcast how to Citizen you do such a
good job of it being kind of action
oriented and even in the show notes and
everything having like links and
suggestions and like actions for people
to take so
um if baritunde's work is is new to you
like check that out it'll give you you
know more than enough uh resources and
and kind of avenues for how does
citizen.com we have the transcripts and
all these actions right every episode
yeah it's so well done
um
you know not just for that for so many
reasons but maybe just as a way to kind
of like round this out and and you know
bring bring this to a conclusion to
share a few of maybe
some of your favorite ways people can
get more engaged and they have
historically
um to energize people around you know
these ideas we're big on
um Frameworks and structures behind the
scenes of the show and we try to show it
and we try to show it on a regular basis
so there's two that matter here one I've
mentioned before but it Bears repeating
we grounded the show in this idea of
Citizen as a verb and there's principles
behind that and so every guests we bring
on kind of checks at least one of these
boxes so there's like there's four four
principles four pillars show up and
participate
is number one number two invest in
relationships with yourself with others
and the planet around you it's no
separation between those things number
three understand power and all the ways
that we have to wield it some are
Financial some are physical some are
idea sharing attention is a big part of
that what we give our attention to we
give power to
and the fourth is to Value the
collective to to do all the above for a
sense of collective self-interest not
merely individual self-interest and and
moderate that over indexing on
individualism that I think has created
too much separation between us to our
Collective demise so that's kind of how
we enter and set things up the way we
leave each episode is we give you three
ways to do something three ways two
citizen
and we got three levels number one
personal reflection we just give you
something to think about in the gaming
metaphor this is like single player mode
and you don't even need an internet
connection right so you can just do this
by yourself there's no public
performance you want to go read a book
so we ask you to think about something
think about
the communities you're a part of
just like you maybe you write them down
maybe you just think aloud to yourself
that could be a book club that could be
an intramural sports team that could be
a a special interest group at your
office that could be a guild that you're
a part of as a worker or a laborer it
could be a union
all the communities and societies you're
a part of
I think you'd be surprised
at how much you already belong
to something as just an entry point and
then you might escalate that to
how am I showing up in that space what
kind of relationships do I have there
how is that Community making its
decisions who's got power in it do I
have any
do people set agendas could I affect
that just the awareness of it so that's
an example of like the light touch
personal reflection number two out of
three
get more informed let's go learn some
[__] you know there's like we don't have
to reinvent everything and so that's get
out there read a book watch a little
video short or a documentary
um talk to someone who's going through
something and and so we have asked
people to talk to young people in their
lives and find out from them in their
educational environment like what
what they're struggling with don't just
trust the newspaper you might have some
young people in this community you've
identified ask them directly I mean so
much more when you hear from someone you
already know then some intermediary no
shade on journalism
or
um
understand the history of your community
there is
Liberation and knowing where you've come
from it helps open a path of where you
could go in a more honest sense and so
we've packaged resources specifically
for people on topics or we've encouraged
them to find them themselves in the
climate realm it's just like look
type into your favorite search engine
climate action and the name of your town
and find out what you could do locally
I'm not saying ignore Washington I'm
saying prioritize your city your county
because that's where you're going to
build relationships that matter and
that's going to produce the national
legislation you're going to be proud of
and then the last of three is public
participation and that's the multiplayer
gaming mode that's playing with others
join something
start it or join it let's start with
finding out what already exists you know
their citizens climate lobbies there are
ways to support local sports teams
there's a thousand volunteer
organizations that can help Channel
that sense of
purpose into something positive and
productive uh the word one of the worst
things we can do with our pent up
anxieties rages and negative emotions
is just look at the screen and scroll
it's a really unhealthy outlet for our
capacity and we can like a thing we can
download a thing we can pop off with no
you know waiting period for the post to
go live
or we can go outside
and like help sandbag around a community
that's preparing for a flood and I
promise you you will feel so much better
doing that than listening to someone
else tell you who's to blame for your
problems
I got some work I gotta do we all do
yeah we all doing the beauty but that's
the thing about it we all do the way you
talk about this stuff and and and you
know perhaps part of your gift is I can
listen to the episodes and I can hear
all this stuff and and of course I'm
reflecting I I immediately reflect on
like how much better you know what all
the things I'm not doing or whatever but
like you do it in a way where it's like
I don't feel like guilty or ashamed as
much as I feel encouraged or empowered
we want this my energy what I bring to
this is inviting energy not shaming
energy I'm capable of wagging my finger
in your face and making you feel bad
about that thing you didn't do with that
thing you don't know
but I know what that feels like and it's
not good I would much rather be invited
to the party
than being shamed for my lack of
presence there and that goes for voting
that goes for any kind of civic
participation that goes for showing up
in a relationship let's welcome people
at least as the first step shame can be
called for some people need to be
ashamed they should be ashamed of their
behavior they're setting bad examples
but
as a starting point I think an
invitation is a much better way to go I
agree man
um beautiful uh I really appreciate you
coming here today man I appreciate you
um you know a huge supporter of the work
that you do and I just wanna you know uh
acknowledge you for the courage and and
the conviction with which you you know
kind of show up for really important
stuff so
uh meant a lot to me to have you come
here today and share I have really
really enjoyed this conversation man we
went we went deep and I didn't knock
over my espressos no you didn't and I
didn't I didn't ask you anything that
was in my outline so that's for sure so
glad you did all that but you bring back
for that I will absolutely come back for
a part two on this yes this is the the
depth and level of uh kind of
conversation I really enjoy and is rare
yeah so thanks for creating this space
it's really powerful um cool man and if
people want to check out more of what
you have to offer they can go to Puck
obviously yeah how to Citizen
um where else do you wanna direct
America Outdoors season two's coming out
yes it's gonna start airing Wednesday
September 6th at 8 pm Eastern Standard 9
p.m Central yeah again on PBS and it's
you know it's all available in the PBS
Video app which I think of as like the
people streaming app it's so good and it
doesn't Harvest your data or give you uh
terrible ads so support the PBS video
dare they not take your day already
paying for it you might as well benefit
[Music]
um and yeah and I'm on the socials
wherever baritone days are found I've
claimed all the names right on cool man
thanks thank you cheers peace